good evening Barclays Bank and its chief
executive are being investigated by
regulators over their handling of a
whistleblowers identity Barkley says
Jess Daly's pay will be cut after he
attempted to identify an anonymous
source who had raised concerns about
another staff member in a memo to bank
employees mr. Staley said he got too
personally involved as he tried to
uncover the whistleblower someone who
knows the difficulties faced by
whistleblowers Nicholas Wilson who's
campaigned for years about alleged
wrongdoing at HSBC he claims that
hundreds of thousands of customers lost
out because of unreasonable debt
collection charges imposed by two of the
bank subsidiaries I asked him how his
life has changed since he spoke out it's
hell especially I think if you whistle
blowing against banks and I've been
insulted patronized mainly mostly by the
media I have to say shut down censored
but ultimately tried to try to be
portrayed as somebody who's not you know
a slightly nutcase or conspiracy
theorist it's destroyed my life I
haven't worked properly since I blew the
whistle when you blew the whistle on
activity at HSBC you went to the
financial services authority which is
the predecessor to the financial conduct
authority which is now investigating
Barclays today do you think attitudes
towards whistleblowers have changed
among the regulator's no I mean there's
a lot of window dressing now it's the
same with banks they've they've made the
bags appoint a whistleblower champion
but we've heard today
I mean Douglas Flint said two years ago
the HSBC chairman yeah the HSBC chairman
Douglas Flint said that the Chartered
Institute of securities investments
he said that whistle bird should be
celebrated and rewarded I'm still
waiting what would be your advice then
to someone who works for a large bank or
a financial services organization who's
thinking of blowing the whistle well
it's career suicide my my advice is
don't do it now because of the hell I've
been through if you're in the health
service or a build
or something and life depends on it and
of course you should but I think in
finance they will win at the end of the
day although actually having said that
after 14 years I'm beginning to see some
progress but it's I wouldn't say it's
been worth it and if people say would
you do it again knowing what I now know
I wouldn't know well we contacted HSBC
but they've not commented in a recent
statements on the subject the bank said
this is a historical issue dating back
to the period between 2003 and 2009 we
have revisited the debt collection
charge and as a result a small number of
HFC and John Lewis Financial Services
Limited customers may be due a refund
Philipp Olga is a banking expert who is
currently writing a book about Barclays
Philip yet again Barclays self finds
itself in meshed in a regulatory
investigation this is very embarrassing
for banking and very embarrassing for
Barclays in particular it's embarrassing
for banking because the industry has an
atrocious record at misleading customers
gaming the rules and actually being very
hard on people who do try to blow the
whistle but the bulk is in particular
it's it's it's worth in a sense because
it's a bank with a troubled history in
recent years but which in the last year
or two has just been showing signs that
it is turning the corner and I think
it's the timing of it as much as the
fundamental issue that will be really
annoying for them that is the iron isn't
it as you say just daily before he set
foot in the bank had had a memo
circulated to Barclays colleagues where
he said he wanted to put ethical conduct
at the heart of what he did with the
bank
he was seen as making quite good
progress wasn't he certainly the
business has started to turn around very
nicely at the previous chief executive
anthony jenkins so cut it right back and
got into tidy kind of shape Staley has
begun to grow it again the industry
conditions have turned much much kinder
for him but that has to be matched with
an absolutely pristine clean ethical
image and this is an embarrassing
episode image you asked Philip is there
something in the water at Barclays
because we have Bob diamonds who went
after the LIBOR rigging affair he and
his predecessor John Varley both
being investigated by the Serious Fraud
Office over this fundraising they did in
o8 it said just something really
culturally amiss at Barclays it does
what make you wonder doesn't it II and
whether there is something about
Barclays you mentioned that I'm writing
a book about them going right back into
the 1980s and most of the chairman and
chief executives that I've met going
back to that period have something to
regret about about the way that they
left there is something about the bank
that's why it's a pity in a sense that
this has happened because Staley was
making the right kind of moves the right
kind of music now I'm told that the
Barclays Board met for four hours
yesterday to discuss his face do you
think it was in the balance do you think
it was possible that he might have lost
his job over this well I think much
depends actually now on the the outcome
of the the PRA and and the FCA inquiries
we have a clue as to the rest of the way
that the authorities might be thinking
in a speech made recently by the
governor of the Bank of England Mark
Carney if you remember a couple of weeks
ago one of his senior people the
Charlotte hog had to resign over a
conflict which owes to resign over a
conflict of interest a few days after
that the governor made an interesting
speech she said we don't operate a
regime where it's one strike an out he
said that an honest mistake openly
admitted and dealt with proper procure
Utley by the institution is not a firing
offense so provided that his investment
of the pr8 investigation reveals that
this was the case of an honest mistake
then jets laila should be okay but we
have to wait and see how it pans out and
of course that was very much the
language that was used in the Barclays
statements are not an honest mistake but
they're having their own investigation
into how they deal with whistleblowers
is there a problem with how we deal with
whistleblowers in this country generally
I mean the number of people taking
complaints of the FCA fell by a fifth
last year and so I mean whistleblowing
is absolutely essential in any industry
it's particularly important in banking
where there is this poor track record in
terms of taking complaints seriously we
have to learn from the mistakes of the
past don't we we have to learn from
episodes like this and actually just
ensure that in future we leave things to
compliance leave things to the people
whose job it is to investigate these
take them seriously and deal with them
proportionately any word for it should
we be paying whistle blows to come
forward as they do in America I think
that well I think that will give the
wrong message there won't be something
about British culture that enables us to
do this in a balanced fair proportionate
way